hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar understanding fiber in
laboratory rodent diets definitions
measurements and adjustments
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by invigo to learn more about our
sponsor please visit invigo.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Derek Martin PhD Rd senior laboratory
animal nutritionist at invigo Derek you
may now begin your presentation
thank you for that introduction hello
everyone thanks for joining me today the
topic of fiber in animals diets is one
about which we receive a lot of requests
this ranges from how much fiber is in
their standard diet to wanting to do
custom diets if you've seen our white
paper on fiber that was an effort to
create a document that addressed many of
the questions that we get this
presentation is a further expansion on
on that white paper so what what will we
be talking about today
we'll first talk about the two primary
types of diets for laboratory animals
and second we'll go over the definition
and the measurement of fiber and third
we'll talk about how we typically go
about formulating custom fiber-adjusted
diets and so what this presentation is
not is is not a review of literature
concerning the effects of fiber in some
disease state or some area of Interest I
will briefly discuss how the presence or
absence of fiber can affect data
interpretation but this is really a a
consideration of these technical issues
about fiber in
animal diets
so first off with the diet types and
ingredients used in laboratory rodent
diets
so you may be thinking why is he
starting by talking about diets and not
fiber in a presentation about fiber
addressing this now will provide the
necessary background for some later
information additionally this
distinction between natural ingredient
diets and purified diets is often behind
many of the questions that we get about
fiber and many other topics
grain-based and natural ingredient can
generally be used interchangeably I've
listed some of the most common primary
ingredients here natural ingredient
diets may also include alfalfa meal
lesser amounts of beet bulk and animal
byproducts such as fish meal or pork fat
however they are still largely made of
grains and soybean meal a standard diet
ciao and normal diet are terms which
would also fall under this category
these terms are often used when
referring to these diets but I try not
to use them because they do lack
specificity some customers will refer to
any diet for lab animals as child
so custom diets such as though as our
salt adjusted series would also fall
into this category as they were made
primarily of grain so custom diets can
also fall into this category
standard diets
and by that I mean those diets that are
fed to animals in an Animal Facility by
default are formulated to meet broad
objectives such as breeding or
maintenance many are are suitable for
studies where nutrients don't need to be
specifically manipulated but they should
be chosen with intention in these types
of diets each primary ingredient
provides a mixture of macronutrients
micronutrients fiber and non-nutrients
so fiber is not an ingredient in these
diets is for this reason that we can't
remove fiber or other nutrients we'll
often be asked to make a diet deficient
in some nutrient or amino acid or Fiber
based on an animal facilities diet and
because of these reasons that's just not
possible
these types of diets may also contain
non-nutrients such as phytoestrogens or
environmental contaminants
there are some inherent variability in
ingredients due to various environmental
factors this could include fiber
specific amino acids and other
non-nutrient
such as the iPhone 5 forms
so for purified diets our next major
class of diets are made for more refined
ingredients where each ingredient
typically provides primarily one
nutrient common ingredients include
casein starch sugars cellulose specific
oils vitamins and minerals the refined
nature of this type of diet allows for
more precise control over micronutrients
micronutrients and fiber
casein is the most common protein source
other sources of protein in purified
diets include whey protein isolated soy
protein egg white solids or individually
added amino acids
carbohydrate is typically provided by
cornstarch maltodextrin and sucrose
other carbohydrate sources are also
available fat sources can vary soybean
oil is included in many diets to supply
essential fatty acids and these types of
diets there are limited non-nutrients
and variability is limited I also throw
in that pretty much anytime you see a
high fat that being used in a diet is
most likely a purified diet
the green ingredients use a natural
ingredient diets are rich in complex
complex plant polysaccharides and fiber
of both insoluble and soluble types the
ingredients that you can see here at the
top of the slide are ground prior to
pelleting Extrusion
the diets themselves have a textured tan
appearance you can see they're in the
bottom moving from left to right we have
a few examples of a pelleted diet and
then two different extruded diets
so here I'm really wanting to emphasize
the highly refined nature of purified
diets as you can see everything is just
white
diets made from purified ingredients are
generally more processed than even the
most highly processed human diet
purified diets are generally an
off-white color unless a specific food
coloring is added as you can see in some
of the examples down there at the bottom
the highly refined nature of these
ingredients and diets makes it possible
for us to control and modify research
variables
so so the distinction between natural
ingredient and purified diets is very
important in general we recommend that
customers not draw any conclusions about
specific nutrients When comparing a
natural ingredient diet to a purified
one they really represent two different
dietary patterns so when you're reading
a paper you want to keep this in mind if
the control diet is reported you want to
ask if it is inappropriate control and
if the conclusions are warranted this
applies to research about fiber minerals
such as iron and research and obesity
atherosclerosis or Nash
these details often go unreported and
leaves a reader and future researchers
unable to do their own interpretation
and it also prevents a hurdle to
research root for disability
Warren and fisler surveyed 35 papers
using high-fat diets
and evaluated what type of control diet
was being used as you've seen this graph
here 34 of the papers didn't provide
sufficient detail to even make that
determination and how this might affect
research interpretation can be seen in
this example here they fed a grain based
low-fat diet a purified low-fat diet and
a high fat diet with 40 kilocalories
from fat
although energy intake was similar in
both low-fat diet groups and both were
lower than the high fat diet group body
weight increased faster in the purified
low-fat diet group than it did in the
grain-based low fat diet group
accordingly body weight gain was only
different between the grain-based
low-fat diet and the purified high fat
diet so had they not included the
purified low-fat diet they may have
concluded that the fat content was
solely responsible for weight gain it's
a why am I including this you just want
to be very careful when reading papers
reporting the effects of different diets
on pretty much any parameter
the next thing we'll talk about is the
definition and measurement of fiber
the one definition put forth is
polysaccharides with a degree of
polymerization greater than 10 that are
resistant to digestion and absorption in
the upper bowel and could then be
fermented in the gut
the degree of polarization or DP is the
number of monomeric units in a
macromolecule or polymer
so that raises the question what about
saccharides with a DP of less than 10.
why would they be excluded by the
arbitrary difference of just one monitor
oligosaccharides with a
DP of three to nine are not measured
within the accepted aoac methods for
measuring dietary fiber so that's one
reason however the Codex illuminataries
commission and the FDA do accept as part
of their definition of dietary fiber to
include
carbohydrates with a degree of
polymerization of three to nine so what
definition am I going to be using so we
start out with carbohydrates that are
resistant to digestion and absorption in
the upper gastrointestinal tract with no
specification on the degree of
polymerization however this definition
leaves out lignin which is also
considered to be fiber
and it is gender and it is captured as
part of many insoluble fiber measurement
methods in the past this definition
was limited to carbohydrates from plants
at times it was limited to plant cell
walls and considering the physiological
definition there's no reason to limit it
to plant material so for example there's
a carbohydrate from
shrimp called chitin that is sometimes
used in fiber studies so other than
stating that fiber is carbohydrate and
maybe the non-carbohydrate lignin the
definition is physiological and that is
that it can't be digested there's not a
structural or analytical definition of
fiber and that's a key point we'll
return to that point later
there are a number of different ways to
categorize or classify fibers fibers can
first be categorized based on their
solubility the definition of flyable
fiber has been the ability to be fully
dispersed when mixed with water
however polysaccharides
classified as soluble may be quite
variable in their actual solubility in
water Additionally the gastrointestinal
tract is not merely an aqueous
environment has a changing environment
as the food moves along the pH the
presence of bile acids and other buffers
can change the solubility of a given
fiber type for instance the solubility
of cellulose depends on ph
polymer length and of course the
concentration
so soluble fibers include pectins inulin
gums and some hemicellulosis
insoluble fibers include cellulose
lignin other hemicellulosis and
resistant starch
fibers may also be classified by their
fermentability
whether or not something is fermentable
is going to depend on what microbes are
present so ruminants have cellulitic
bacteria which is relatively uncommon
for ruminants and if you were to
introduce a fiber that is generally
considered fermentable for example
pectin to a germ-free mouse then that
fiber isn't fermentable in that context
although it's generally true that
soluble fibers tend to be fermentable
and inflatable fibers are not this is
not an absolute rule particularly with
inflatable fibers
although it essays as an insoluble fiber
resistant starch behaves much more like
a soluble one in terms of fermentability
further be classified based on functions
or characteristics such as water holding
capacity viscosity bulking absorption of
other compounds
encapsulation so these are some other
functions that may be used to categorize
fiber the source of fiber can also be
used to differentiate them Apple pectin
is often differentiated from
citruspectin
as for structures cellulose is a beta14
beta14 linked glucose polymer lignin is
a
the polymer of phenolics and other
non-finalic subunits
pectin is composed primarily as a
galacturonic acid and then it can be
verb to classified based on whether or
not it is a high or low methoxy pectin
there's a range of different ways that
we can categorize or classify fibers
here's a graph just showing the
different solubilities of insoluble
fibers at varying pH levels this is just
to reiterate that whether or not
something is soluble or insoluble is
dependent on the context so you see as
the pH gets to either the more acidic
condition or the more basic conditions
of fibers that generally become more
soluble
so next we'll have a cursory glance at
fiber measurement I'm only going to
cover here the two fiber measurements
listed on our data sheets this could be
a this section here can itself can be a
very long presentation there's a lot of
very technical detail that is
I'm not addressing here so remember from
a few slides ago that the definition of
fiber is physiological
thus there's difficulty in developing
analytical methods for measuring fiber
that actually correspond to the
physiological definition
if you search for fiber on the aoac
website you'll find 34 different methods
and those are just the official methods
there
are numerous modifications and
refinements that are continually being
worked on and published
the first measurement I'll talk about is
Crew fiber is performed by extraction
with boiling
Alkali and acid Solutions which were the
known characteristics of digestion of
the digestion process at that time
that it was developed so crude fiber
served as the de facto definition of
fiber for about 100 years however the
recovery of different fiber fractions by
this method varies considerably you can
see here that it's anywhere it recovers
anywhere from 40 to 100 of the cellulose
15 to 20 percent of the pittosins from
hemicellulose anywhere from five to
ninety percent of the lignin uh the
crude fiber measurement
lacks a strong relationship to any
nutritional definition of fiber and it
has not really proven to advance
understanding about physiological
responses to dietary fiber or an impact
on the digestibility so in summary crude
fiber is a value resulting from a
specific analytical methodology and
overall it underestimates the True Value
it isn't a substance and doesn't provide
a much meaningful information with
respect to the physiological definition
of fiber
neutral detergent fiber is the best
measurement or estimate that we have for
insoluble fiber
is initially designed to isolate
insoluble fiber from plant cell walls
the it primarily measures cellulose
hemicellulose and lignin
and the ndf method involves enzymatic
removal of starch removal of protein and
fat with detergent followed by
gravimetric quantification of the fiber
there are a number of difficulties in
determining fiber content or if you were
to ask you know what is the fiber
content of my diet here's some of the
kind of considerations that we have
running in the background
we use published values of fiber
measurements for grain ingredients in
estimating fiber content many of these
Publications were printed 30 plus years
ago and may not reflect the most
up-to-date methods of Performing the
analyzes additionally there's some
variability in the composition of the
agricultural products themselves due to
numerous factors
so there are limited publish values for
soluble fiber in these grain ingredients
the interest insoluble fiber came from
Human nutrition where it was found to
have beneficial health effects while the
measurement of soluble fiber has been
done on many human foods similar
information isn't as available for the
agricultural commodity products that
make up laboratory animal diets
agricultural animal nutritionists in the
past didn't find it important enough to
formulate for so the animal so excuse me
so the analytical methodologies that
weren't applied as widely
uh the methods themselves don't measure
everything we want to measure for
example the ndf method May underestimate
hemicelluluses
these estimates do not account for
changes in fiber measurements that
result from further processing such as
pelleting Extrusion during these
processes certain carbohydrate fractions
can be chemically altered and no longer
show up as fiber in a given method
method of measurement
piloted diets likely contain more
resistant starch than extruded diets
because they are subjected to less
cooking during the manufacturing process
furthermore other complexes such as my
yard reaction products or lignin protein
complexes may increase what is measured
as fiber in these methods
one of the great difficulties in
determining fiber is the lack of
Correspondence between the physiological
definition and analytical methods so no
one analytical method yet developed Maps
perfectly onto the physiological
definition of fiber
beyond that many of the common
measurements leave some variables
unaccounted for just as an example the
digestive digestibility values of
cellulose and hemicellulosis Vary
according to their degree of
crystallinity or acetylation and they're
interlinking with lignin and sometimes
silica and this is just not going to be
picked up by
those chemical analytical methods
we've talked about the ingredients used
in diets for live animals and the
definition and measurement of fiber in
that context I'd like to go over how to
read a standard diet beta sheet so here
I've just pictured the
data sheet for our 2018 Tech live Global
rodent diet
first thing you want to look at is the
ingredients list
what is listed here is going to tell you
whether you're looking at a natural
ingredient diet or a purified diet so
those two major classes of diets that we
went over at the beginning
diet formulas may be either closed or
open this refers to whether or not the
formula is made available to the public
other than the NIH diets all of our
standard diets are closed meaning that
the inclusion rate of each of the
ingredients is proprietary
diet formulas may also be either fixed
or variable another term for variable
would be managed
in fixed formulas the inclusion rate of
the ingredients is not changed all of
our standard diets are fixed formulas
there is some natural variation in the
composition of each ingredient and thus
the final composition will reflect that
moving on from the ingredients list
our fiber estimates are listed under the
macronutrient subsection
so you see under under the macronutrient
subsection we have both the the crude
fiber measurement and the ndf
measurement
um it's important to remember
that the ndf and Crew fiber are not
additive
so you can't add them together to see
how much fiber you have so what about
soluble fiber
it's not listed here we generally
estimate that there's somewhere between
two and five percent soluble fiber for
grain-based diets
the last thing we'll talk about is
custom fiber adjusted diets
when you contact us about a
fiber-adjusted diet we'll work through a
series of questions to clarify what
you're looking for we'll consider the
purpose of the study whether you're
trying to increase fecal bulk or want to
increase fermentable fiber
whether or not you need a radiation
whether or not something needs to be
irradiated is primarily related to the
amount of vitamins that need to be
included into the diet we're not really
considering fiber at this point and
we'll get into a few of these other
considerations on the next slide
for custom fiber adjusted diets will
typically start with a low or no fiber
based diet and then add fiber
so we'll have the Ain 763 6A the 93m 93g
diet as well as a couple other diets
td130343 and
td-00278 so the Ain diets uh the
carbohydrate is primarily provided by
cornstarch sucrose and maltodextrin in
one three zero three four three and zero
zero two seven eight
they both have a good chunk of dextrose
that replaces that effectively replaces
cornstarch
and those are just a couple different
starting places that we have the next
step would be to add we can also add a
fiber to high-fat diets like td8107 or
06414
the next thing to consider would be how
much fiber to add and the the type of
fiber that you would want to add
the next thing would be the feasibility
of manufacturing so pectin and inulin
are somewhat sticky and can function
sometimes like maltodextrin in terms of
providing cohesion to the pellets so too
much fiber can make mixing and or
pelleting difficult
we've had pretty decent success
including 30 total pectin and or inulin
into purified diets particularly when
maltodextrin is excluded
and the last thing is some physiological
considerations there can be some
gastrointestinal distress with diets
with higher pectin or inulin content
for 30 percent pectin we do have
feedback from One customer in that the
mice had experienced some weight loss
had an enlarged cecum and their feces
had a gummy texture nothing customer
reported that mice with 10 pectin had
more mild symptoms no dramatic weight
loss however there was still the
slightly large cecum incoming feces
present
so we don't have any feedback on diets
with a combination of pectin and inulin
totaling 10 or greater
those are just some observations that we
do have so weight loss gummy PCS and or
other GI disturbances are potential
risks of diets high in soluble fiber
uh next I'd like to go over some of the
four sources of fiber that we can
include cellulose is often considered
inert with respect to the microbiota
it's function in diet is to provide bulk
and or reduce energy density
we have pectin our force of protection
is from citrus peel
inulin and hylon 7 hilon 7
is approximately is a cornstarch that is
approximately 70 mlos and 30 percent
envelop pectin and just as a source of
resistant starch the type of resistant
starch in this is Type 2 or rs2
where the starch is tightly packed in a
radial pattern and largely inaccessible
to the enzymes in the small intestine
and I have here a question mark As
cornstarch so regular cornstarch has
approximately 25 amylose and 70
amylopectin so it's almost the inverse
of the hilon 7. we infer that there may
be some resistant starch associated with
the amylose portion but we're not
entirely sure about its levels
you can also include a customer supplied
ingredients as a source of fiber we have
fructo
oligosaccharides
galactosaccharides and oligosaccharides
that have been included chitin from
shrimp chills
we've also included fruit vegetable or
other plant matter I did look earlier
this morning and we've actually done one
formulation with a purified inulin no
excuse me a purified lignin so that's a
you know another possibility
so
one question we get contact got
contacted about is the question that
goes something like do you have a high
fiber Mouse diet and my question
learning in the background is well
compared to what I I don't know what you
think high fiber is
so here's some preliminary context to
help you answer that question
the the
Badger reference intakes are established
by The Institute of Medicine
the adequate intake is one of the
Dietary Reference index that has less
certainty than the some of the other
values but the adequate intake is 14
grams per 1000 kilocalories
for a human diet uh natural ingredient
diets
contain about 40 to 50 grams of fiber
per 1000 calories and according to
inhanes data the typical American diet
has eight to ten grams of fiber per 1000
calories
it just as another example the Ain 93g
diet has about 13 grams of fiber per
1000 calories that is from cellulose
dd8137 has about 11 grams per 1000
calories that also is from cellulose
so uh the standard diet you're already
feeding likely is a high fiber diet it
represents at minimum a four-fold
increase in the energy adjusted fiber
content of the average American diet
I've just given an overview about how we
go about formulating custom fiber
adjusted diets so how do these diets
compare to grain-based diets
in addition to
addition of fiber to purified diets has
had mixed results on microbiota
diversity measurements and where
diversity is increased that doesn't mean
that the microbial populations are
similar so they've made even if they
have increased diversity the grain-based
diet and the purified diet may not have
similar microbiota
carbohydrate excuse me purified diets do
not mimic the carbohydrate complexity
found in grain-based diets brain-based
diets have a number of different fiber
types involved in complex interactions
with one another for purified diets
types of available types of fiber
available for addition are limited and
even if we were to add a purified fiber
to a purified diet we're not recreating
the intermolecular structure that
three-dimensional structure that is
present
in the grain ingredients themselves this
may change the way the fibers are
available to interact with microbes
present within the GI tract so the
answer
to the question posed in the title of
this
slide is no probably not
so can I add fiber to my standard diet
remember that the ingredients in
standard diets are complex and cannot be
reduced to their constituent parts and
so we cannot remove fiber
only additions of fiber and then it is
at the expense of diluting the rest of
the diet
so doing this probably does not
meaningfully impact the total fiber
content that much at least when you
consider the vast difference between
purified diets and grain-based diets
but it may be useful to intentionally
increase soluble fiber
cellulose is often considered inner with
respect to the microbiota adding
cellulose basically just dilutes the
diet and reduces the energy density and
this is actually often a strategy
strategy
for making diets intended to be used for
caloric restriction experiments
continuing with the theme of standard
diets will occasionally be asked about
making a version of a standard diet
using purified ingredients
this may be to manipulate fiber or some
other variable given what we've gone
over so far I think you can understand
why that would be a dubious proposition
matching formulations nutrient contents
on paper does not mean that they
resemble each other physiologically
to illustrate how this can play out here
we have an example of liver iron stores
and mice that different diets so these
mice
were retained at three weeks old and
placed on their respective diets for
four weeks prior to mating
microsite mice were sacrificed and the
tissues were taken on gestational day 17
mice were fed either a standard diet
with 220 parts per million iron a
purified custom diet with 200 parcelain
iron or a purified custom diet with 45
BPM iron
you hear that liver iron was higher in
the 200 PPM diet
in the in excuse me liver iron was
higher in the purified 200 PPM diet than
in the grain based 200 PPM diet
and the grain base 220 PPM diet and the
purified diet with about 45 parts per
million led to nearly equal outcomes
examples of this could be multiplied
with protein or other nutrients
just that the digestibility
availability and utilization of
different nutrients is very different
between a grain-based diet and a
purified diet so if you're wanting to
make a purified version of your standard
diet so that you can manipulate fiber or
some other nutrient for that matter I
would try to dissuade you from that
so in summary I've discussed the two
major diet types and ingredient sets
that are used to make laboratory rodent
diets we talked about the definition of
fiber the key Point here is that the
definition is physiological
this physiological definition sets up a
difficulty in measuring fiber and to
develop analytical methods that map
perfectly on to the physiological
definition
we then walk through and outlined the
process of creating a custom
fiber-adjusted diet and the things that
need to be considered thank you for your
interest and I appreciate you taking
time to join us
the um
this slide um
I think we'll be taking questions but I
also have some references that may be of
interest to you particularly with
respect to measuring fiber in Grain
ingredients
thank you Derek for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar I have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started
Derek our first question here asks
within the measurements on the data
sheet where is soluble fiber actually
showing up
we're actually gonna
it's probably if you want to be
accounted for in the
uh available carbohydrate section
so
I looked at that uh
excuse me
I do have a slide for this actually
so when we calculate
this
we're actually doing the a nitrogen free
extract
as 100 minus the moisture plus plus
screw fiber plus fat and protein and the
available carbohydrate is another
equation so
the soluble fiber is actually going to
be included into that available
carbohydrate number
great thank you
next question here
uh looks like this is a two-part
question and this question asks when
designing a murine diet experiment where
fiber is studied at a high content how
can I choose the correct low content
fiber diet and the second part of this
question asks what ingredients would be
removed from the high fiber diet to
result in a low fiber diet
so
and generally you would we would you
know work in consultation with the
potential customer to design the
formulas and it it's kind of a
collaborative process to design the
formulas
and so when we're asking about what
ingredient would be removed from the
high fiber diet to result in a low fiber
diet
if we're going through the process that
I had laid out for how we'd normally go
about it we would basically start with a
low fiber diet and then add in fiber and
that's generally done at the expense of
either cellulose so it may if we start
out with the Ain 93m formula
you know we may add fiber at the let's
say we may add a soluble fiber at the
expense of cellulose or we may add it at
the expense of cornstarch or something
like that
so uh what ingredient would be removed
from the high fiber diet as long as that
question isn't in reference to a
grain-based diet where you know we can't
remove
fiber from a grain-based diet it may be
you know maybe we think about it from
starting with the low fiber diet and
then moving to the high fiber diet
great thank you next question here how
do you plan for High versus low fiber
diet in germ-free mice
okay
um
there again that is going to depend on
which diet types we're talking about so
if we're talking about
high fiber
with
purified diets you know we can work on a
matching
set of diets for observative mice the
primary considerations for example free
mice would be you know they
the diets themselves would need to be
vacuum packaged and irradiated and with
irradiation we have higher vitamin
inclusion rates for those
but if you're asking about
comparing a
a grain-based diet to a
purified diet you have to keep in mind
the the differences between those two
types of diets and they're just very
different things
great thank you
another question for you here asks on
average what is the time mice need to be
in the new fiber diet in order to study
its impact on phenotypes
um
in the context
but I think that's going to depend
specifically on what your what
uh
what what outcome you're looking at you
can see in the uh from the the one slide
that I went over with
the the weight gain in the
purified diet and the two different oh
the the high fat diet and the two
different low-fat diets uh you know it
took takes a little bit of time for
those
uh measurements to kind of spread out so
that's going to be something that takes
longer as far as microbiota changes they
see those changing very quickly but
it depends on what specific
characteristic that you're asking about
great thank you
next question here and it has a bit of
context before the question
RPI wanted to do an experiment with
cellulose in the concentrations of 0 6
12 and 40 percent we found this to not
be the best approach especially with 40
fiber any thoughts on how to improve the
design of these groups to look at the
impact of a different percentage of
fiber as a starting point for an
experiment
I I think I would want to know what
specific objections there were for that
not being the best approach so
um just looking at it at face value if
we were to use a purified diet you could
basically have everything
matched at least on a weight for weight
basis with all of those
cellulose inclusion rates so I I would
be really curious as to what the
specific uh problem that they were
encountering with those formulations was
great
next question here are every batch of or
are every batches of these diets analyze
the fiber
with respect to our standard diets
no so those
we're calculating those values from
uh
the the green ingredients themselves and
if you're if we're doing a custom diet
then those
we're not doing any analysis after the
fact so we're going to have the specific
formula and then there are some internal
production
measure measures that we have that's not
the right word excuse me there's some
internal production
quality controls that we do to ensure
that the diet is made according to the
formulation
great
next question what utility does the
crude fiber measurement have
so
in historically it has been used as part
of the approximate analysis
to and it can be useful for
uh
determining if a given feed has been
adulterated uh but after its problems
with
you know actually serving as a
measurement for fiber were kind of
worked out
um
it's it's utility as a fiber measurement
isn't very good even though it may still
retain some utility for feed
adulteration
and I think a lot of customers just
expect to see the crude fiber
measurement on a
on a data sheet
great
well Derek thank you again do you have
any final comments for our audience
uh I'll just saying that um you know
we're we're happy to work with customers
to help them think through a diet or
anything from the Middle Design and uh
have a lot of fun doing it so you can
get in touch with us
great
well Derek thank you for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor in Vigo for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labords will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye